bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches pour
une fois on ne vous parlera pas
d'économie française mais d' économie
européenne
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du smic européen bonjour estelle
bonjour olivier bonjour à tous bienvenue
dans ces caches les 7 et 8 mai dernier
s'est tenu à porto au portugal un sommet
social des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de l'union européenne
l'occasion pour les vingt-sept d'aborder
le sujet d'un smic européen
une idée qui n'est pas nouvelle et dont
on va parler dans cette émission et pour
cela en deuxième partie nous serons en
liaison avec véronique riches florès
économiste et présidente de riches
florès reasearch en octobre 2020
l'exécutif européen a présenté une
directive relative à des salaires
minimaux adéquat dans l'union européenne
objectif combattre la pauvreté et
permettre aux bénéficiaires de salaires
minimaux de gagner leur vie décemment
notamment en promouvant les négociations
collectives étant donné chez les
compétences limitées de la commission
européenne en matière sociale au sein de
l'union il n'y aura finalement pas pour
le moment de rémunération minimale
unique au niveau de lieux
mais le sujet est tout de même revenue
sur la table tous les détails avec le
tiroir cage d'antoine d'assas le smic
européen
c'est un sujet qui revient régulièrement
à bruxelles ces dernières années
rien d'étonnant puisque chaque pays de
l'union européenne à son propre salaire
minimum au sein même de lieu
les disparités sont énormes si vous êtes
un travailleur bulgare votre smic
s'élèvera un peu plus de 300 euros alors
que si vous êtes luxembourgeois il sera
proche de 2 mx 1,50 euro cette fois plus
élevés et chez six pays membres
l'autriche chypre le danemark la
finlande l'italie et la suède
il n'y a carrément pas de salaire
minimum pas étonnant donc que les
entreprises se délocalisent au sein même
mon dans ces pays sans smic ou au smic
très bas cela leur permet ainsi
d'économiser très largement sur la main
d'oeuvre tout en vendant leurs
marchandises partout sur le territoire
européen
le dossier d'un fils qu européen est
revenu sur la table lors du sommet
social de porto début mai et évidemment
les vingt-sept se sont mis d'accord et
l'ont adopté en fait non pas du tout le
projet est toujours dans l'impasse
forcément c'est complètement impensable
d'uniformiser les salaires deux pays qui
ont autant de disparités y compris sur
le coût de la vie et pour lesquels
parfois pratiquer du dumping social ou
salariales faire venir les entreprises
des pays étrangers chez eux est
primordial pour leur économie
il ya aussi la question des traités qui
rendent l'opération compliqué pour
l'union du moins si elle ne veut pas
manquer de respect à la souveraineté de
ces pays
pas évident donc de s'attaquer aux
salaires le smic européen c'est vraiment
pas pour demain olivier on l'a bien
compris pas de smic européen au menu il
ne s'agit pas d'imposer la fixation d'un
salaire minimum l'union est là pour
encourager la coordination avec un
objectif de convergence sociale vers le
haut et de lutte contre le dumping
social précision de l'elysée alors
comment construire une europe plus
sociale
déjà je pense que le problème c'est
c'est toujours la même chose
c'est-à-dire que les décisions par là de
la commission européenne
ou sinon de paris quand c'est quand ça
concerne la france en ignorons vraiment
ce qui se passe dans les pays et dans
les pays
il ya pour certains des accords de
branche et ils s'y tiennent à ces
accords de branche et ils n'ont pas du
tout l'intention qu'on vienne leur
imposer que la commission que des
fonctionnaires européens viennent leur
imposer des
d un salaire minimum vous avez on l'a
dit dans le dans le tiroir cash vous
avez quand même des niveaux de vie et
qui sont des coûts de la vie qui sont
complètement différent entre la bulgarie
et ou portugal et le luxembourg
donc on voit bien que c'est une espèce
de décision que cherche à imposer la
commission européenne mais ça peut se
faire au niveau des pays
pardon est-ce que c'est nécessaire une
europe plus sociale d'aujourd'hui
mais oui face et c'est nécessaire je
fais je pense pas que ce soit comme ça
qu'on puisse le faire donc de toutes
façons
oui bien évidemment que on préférerait
que tout le monde puisse manger à sa
faim etc
mais d'abord occupons-nous dans nos pays
de ce qui se passe avant de s'occuper de
ça au niveau européen
en france on a quand même une un taux de
pauvreté qui a énormément augmenté et de
grande pauvreté et a énormément augmenté
occupons nous d'abord deux avant de se
poser des questions sur le salaire
minimum qu'on pourrait imposer en
finlande ou en bulgarie
voilà je pense que ça serait déjà bien
merci olivier tout de suite la deuxième
partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec véronique riches florès bonjour
madame vous êtes économiste et
présidente de riches florès reasearch
des revenus dans ces caches
merci bonjour alors on l'a évoqué en
première partie il n'est pas d'actualité
un smic européen notamment parce que les
traités interdisent à la commission de
fixer les salaires au sein des états
elle si l'on passe outre toutes ces
questions à juridique est ce qu un smic
européen est souhaitable selon vous et
sous quelle forme
alors je crois qu'olivier a bien
introduit le sujet une question délicate
quand on a échangé pour préparer cette
émission je vous ai dit à brûle
pourpoint bien sûr qu'un smic européen
serait nécessaire et serait une bonne
décision
néanmoins je crois qui bêtement on a
parlé effectivement du fait que le smic
était pas une réponse unique et que ce
dont on a besoin avant tout en europe
mais sans glisser une europe
effectivement plus sociale notamment et
tout particulièrement après cette crise
et les effets de la crise sanitaire sur
sur la pauvreté sur l'exclusion
on pourrait naturellement parler par
exemple des difficultés du logement qui
est qu'ils sont des difficultés de plus
en plus rencontrer et largement
rencontré en europe et donc finalement
la proposition d'un smic
elle ne sait pas ce que la plus facile
en réalité et
la plus facile encore qu'on voit que
même sur ce point bien évidemment on
n'arrive pas à se mettre d'accord mais
si une proposition qui est un minimum
d'assurance vers une protection ou un
degré de protection paneuropéen qui soit
un petit peu plus efficace c'est dans ce
lac effectivement cette proposition est
d'ailleurs c'est pas pour rien si elle
revient sur la table c'est parce qu'on
est et chacun des pays européens est
face à une montée des inégalités et à
alimenter très violente de la pauvreté
et de l'exclusion
olivier une réaction à une réaction
si vous voulez on est en train de
s'occuper d'un salaire minimum alors que
le problème c'est que on pourrait déjà
trouvé un moyen pour faire baisser le
chômage parce que les chômeurs ils s'en
fichent du salaire minimum ils n'ont pas
de travail donc ils n'ont pas de salaire
donc
occupons nous d'abord de ça je pense que
c'est c'est encore pour moi c'est c'est
un pur coup de com
on voit d'ailleurs que monsieur macron
ram pour essayer de faire passer ça
avant les élections de 2022 donc c'est
encore à un coût politique et voilà
c'est c'est comme comme beaucoup de
choses depuis plusieurs années en
politique on fait des ont fait des
annonces malheureusement il n'y a pas
beaucoup de faits derrière
en plus de ça je vous dis est ce que
c'est un est ce que c'est une obligation
pour les pays notamment ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas les sept pays qui n'en n'ont
pas de salaire minimum de mettre un
salaire minimum ou est ce que on cherche
une convergence des salaires minimum
c'est-à-dire un salaire minimum fixé par
la commission européenne dans tous les
pays et là on voit bien que ça ne
pourrait pas marcher puisque vous avez
des coûts de la vie qui n'ont absolument
rien à voir entre le portugal si vous
êtes allé sur une terrasse au portugal
vous payez pas la même chose que sur la
terrasse rue de la paix c'est ça n'a
rien à voir donc voilà donc cesser c'est
totalement impossible et on le sait et
on a quand même année
double discours delà de l'europe
l'europe qui cherche par exemple à faire
rentrer l'ukraine dans son sein alors
que l'ukraine le salaire et sans eau 100
$ par part moi excusez moi mais c'est
bien pour une bonne raison c'est pour
essayer de faire baisser les salaires
partout c'est ça c'est à ça que ça sert
sa serre ou délocalisation ça fait
délocaliser les entreprises et après on
va avec une petite larme on vous dira
bas il faudrait peut-être penser à faire
un smic européen
c'est ridicule alors olivier vous
évoquez un coup de com pourtant
véronique riches florès les depuis le
sommet social de göteborg en 2017 il ya
en a eu des dispositions législatives
concrètes je pense par exemple aux
directives sur le temps de travail aux
directives aussi sur les travailleurs
détachés
c'est aussi un coup de com pour vous
c'est un peu moins un coup de com on
voit que la directive notamment sur le
temps de travail et quand même imposé et
globalement suivi de la même manière sur
les travailleurs détachés sont des
sujets très importants l'a vécu en
france notamment mais pas seulement
donc je pense qu'effectivement il est
important que la la commission
européenne essaye de réguler cela et tu
as eu de limiter au maximum la tentation
du dumping social qui existe forcément
dans un espace européen que tel qu'il
est actuellement
maintenant la question est effectivement
aussi de quoi on s'occupe est ce qu'on
prend des mesures pour assurer des
effets d'annoncé on a mentionné certains
donc potentiellement le smic ou est ce
qu'on veut une robe beaucoup plus qui se
donne des objectifs et c'est là qu'on on
est tenté d'accepter y compris la preuve
des propositions qu'il ne faut
certainement pas suffisante d'accepter
ses propositions dans l'espoir
qu'effectivement on aille de l'avant
petit à petit comme c'est le cas en
europe
maintenant je vais accepter que cette
approche soit très optimiste finalement
est assez naïve sur la réalité
européenne mais j'ai pas vraiment de
désaccord avec ce qui a été exprimé par
olivier delamarche appréciera donc on
voit bien effectivement on a à la fois
un problème de développement économique
il s'agit pas d'imposer un smic à des
pays durée pas les moyens tout
simplement d'y faire face
il faut le projet européen à l'origine
est un projet de convergence de
développement et d'élévation du niveau
de vie vers les pays les plus riches
c'est pour ça que dans le pays pour ou
plus pauvres sont attirés par cette
intégration à l'europe
ce qu'on constate néanmoins co2 en
général
souvent après avoir intégré le rock la
plupart des pays ont dans un premier
temps passe une marche d'escalier assez
favorable en termes de productivité
l'investissement et c est qu après les
divergences se recrutent
et ça on ne sait pas faire pourquoi
parce qu'effectivement la politique
européenne de développement structurel
au delà des fonds dédiés à certains pays
et iraqi également sont pas toujours
très heureuses en termes de conséquences
d'ailleurs et bien c'est peu et ex truc
tu râles de développement n'existe pas
ou très peu
on a on en a une illustration avec les
plantes le fameux plan de relance
européen qui en réalité est bien bien
limités et donc on risque de ne pas
avoir beaucoup d'effets structurels en
termes précisément d'amélioration de la
productivité et de distribution de ces
gains de productivité avec une meilleure
répartition de ceux-ci à la population
car c'est ça concerne notamment l'emploi
donc le smic a peut-être ça
effectivement nous sommes dans des
sociétés ou l'inclusion marché de
l'emploi est éminemment plus difficile
que dès qu'elle ne l'était il ya 20 ou
30 ans voire davantage et probablement
risque de le devenir de plus en plus
notamment face à la montée des nouvelles
technologies la digitalisation etc
et c'est là qu'on a qu'on a envie de
dire attention il faut peut-être un smic
en tout cas c'est mon avis différenciée
selon les pays et peut-être un objectif
de convergence d'ailleurs avec les
d'augmentation de ce minima de ces
minima sur le long terme mais il nous
faut aussi nous préoccuper de plus en
plus de l'inclusion et des exclus du
marché de l'emploi
et là je pense que c'est plus une
question de salaire minimum bien sûr
mais de d'environnement social européen
et
et de gros efforts sur la formation sur
d'éducation et l'éducation s'est pas
seulement l'éducation au se répartir de
secondaire messi est réellement gros
efforts sur l'éducation dès le primaire
et la l'europe est littéralement absente
ou quasiment
à part quelques projets qui ont souffert
d'ailleurs avec le président je pense
notamment aux yeux au projet erasmus
alors véronique riches florès olivier
ont marqué une courte pause et on
revient dans un instant bienvenue dans
ces caches si vous nous rejoignez au
sommaire cette semaine l'europe sociale
est l'idée d'un smic européen et pour
cela nous sommes en liaison avec
véronique riches florès économiste et
présidente de riches florès reasearch
alors olivier petites questions autour
de cette proposition de la confédération
européenne des syndicats la
confédération proposé en novembre
dernier l'établissement d'un seuil en
dessous en dessous duquel les salaires
minimums légaux ne devrait pas tomber
soit au minimum à 60 % du salaire médian
brut et à 50% du salaire moyen brut ça
pourrait être une bonne piste par
exemple sans vouloir imposer quoi que ce
soit c'est déjà le cas c'est déjà le cas
vous prenez le salaire minimum par
exemple au portugal est quand même très
bas mais qui est à de mémoire 60 60 % ou
60 ans un petit peu plus de 60% du
revenu médian donc c'est déjà le cas
donc qu'il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas
essai pas une proposition extraordinaire
et
puisque dans la plupart des pays vous
êtes autour de ces 60% du revenu médian
donc
rien de nouveau sous le soleil non il ya
il ya quelque chose qui aussi sur lequel
on peut discuter c'est que vous avez
quand même pas mal d'études qui ont été
faites justement sur le smic en disant
que le smic
écarté du marché du travail les gens peu
qualifiés et les jeunes et les gens peu
qualifiés donc que ça avait un effet en
fait contraire à ce que l'on pourrait
penser puisque ça allez sortez de 2 du
jeu c'est à dire du travail parce que
les entreprises ne voulait pas employer
des gens peu qualifiés à au smic donc on
peut se poser aussi la question de
savoir si réellement c'est une bonne
idée mais on est riches florès vous
évoquiez tout vers les objectifs de
l'union européenne alors lors du sommet
social de porto est début mai les
dirigeants des vingt-sept ont approuvé
le plan d'action de la commission il
prévoit trois objectifs à l'horizon 2030
augmenté à 78 % le taux d'emploi formés
chaque année au moins 60 % des adultes
et réduire de 15 millions le nombre des
personnes menacées de pauvreté ou
d'exclusion sociale une évaluation de ce
plan est prévu en 2025 ce sont à des
objectifs qui sont plutôt concret est-ce
qu'ils sont assez ambitieux selon nous
c'est souvent c'est souvent le problème
avec la commission européenne si les
années sur le site de la commission
on découvre quelque chose qui est
idyllique avec des projets des
propositions qui soient sur l'emploi et
compris sur l'aspect environnemental le
social où on
l'impression que l'europe déploie des
moyens et des objectifs très ambitieux
et puis puis à la réalité est ce qu'on
observe au fil du temps où force est de
constater ce qui pas tout à fait la même
chose que ce qu'on observe sur le site
dont pierre et beaucoup de bonne volonté
je dirais que les choses se sont plutôt
améliorée avec l'arrivée de madame van
der leyen c'est depuis deux ans la
question c'est comment comment passe de
4 entre cette ambition est la
concrétisation de ces objectifs et on
s'est beaucoup moins bien faire donc oui
les objectifs sont ambitieux ils sont
assez tentant je pense qu'ils pointent
du doigt d'ailleurs le plus souvent de
réelles questions
la formation professionnelle formation
fil de la vie l'intégration
l'augmentation du taux de participation
surtout dans une économie avec une
population très rapidement vieillissante
est un impératif
reste à savoir comment on y parvient et
manifestement il nous manque un pont
entre ces objectifs et la capacité
d'avancer vers cela la meilleure la
meilleure illustration derrière c'est
effectivement ce que pouvait offrir
comme proposition la commission
européenne quelques années aux nouveaux
entrants termes d'évolution de leur
pouvoir d'achat de l'homme dort niveau
de vie et puisqu'il en a été réellement
donc on voit que ça fonctionne pas il
n'ya pas il n'ya pas les dispositifs
d'accompagnement ou de contrainte
d'ailleurs pour obliger les pays à
avancer vers ces directives qui sont
pour le mont pour le coup là plutôt
séduisante est en général assez bien
ciblés il faut le reconnaître et olivier
vous aide à la grèce est contrainte
annoncé pas une question de contraintes
ou pas moi le déjà je trouve que y'en a
trop avec avec l'europe mais le problème
c'est c'est de mettre ddd
et des fat c'est d'avoir des ambitions
qui sont réalistes
or on sait très bien parce que
malheureusement le l'économie est ce
qu'elle est et les les décideurs
économiques sont ce qu'ils sont et on
sait très bien que ces objectifs ne
resteront que des objectifs sur le
papier le jeudi
rappelez vous quand même la construction
de l'union européenne on nous promettait
quoi on nous promettait plus de
croissance on nous promettait moins de
chômage
on nous promettait plus de pauvreté et
settat et puis dans les pays
c'est le programme de tous les futurs
présidents qui vous annonce que avec eux
il y aura plus personne dans la rue il y
aura plus de chômeurs eux on aura une
croissance de 5 ou 6 % etc
oui sauf que non donc puis en plus on
fait rien pour y parvenir donc c'est
toujours la même chose et on a un
discours qui est un discours pour faire
rêver et puis il ya la dure réalité des
choses qui ne correspond pas vraiment à
ce qu'on nous avait annoncé véronique
riches florès voudrais vous faire réagir
à ces déclarations de l'eurodéputé modem
sylvie brunet c'est évident que si on a
de trop grandes distorsions notamment
sur les conditions sociales ont créé du
dumping social
c'est le principal problème aujourd'hui
le dumping social ça fait partie du
problème je suis ne mettrait pas en
numéro 1 c'est une réalité mais qui
dépasse largement les frontières de
l'europe est fait je pense que on n'a
plus de patron a pris un certain nombre
de décisions aussi les dispositions ces
deux travailleurs détachés aussi n est
qu à l environnement qui est qui qui
protège quand même un petit peu en
europe
le vrai dumping social il vient surtout
de ce qu'on importe est effectivement de
la position de l'europe par rapport au
reste du monde en particulier de l'asie
donc non il me semble que oui enfin dans
ces propos sont assez justes elles ce
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
le point numéro un kim - me préoccupe
je dirais non le point qui me préoccupe
le plus c'est de voir partout de
l'exclusion galopante et finalement
l'absence de mesures chocs de plans de
développement paneuropéen à la hauteur
des enjeux qui sont pas seulement des
enjeux domestique de chacun des pays
mais de la place de l'europe dans le
monde de demain d'ailleurs alors
justement avant de se quitter dernière
question est la pandémie est la crise
que l'on vit aujourd'hui actuellement
est ce qu'elle peut faire évoluer le
regard des européens sur leur modèle
social et est ce que ça pourrait être un
accélérateur d'une europe plus sociale
la crise et surtout pour l'instant un
accélérateur des inégalités et d'une
situation gravissime avec des questions
pour le futur très très inquiétante
est-ce que
là le choc saucier les chocs sociétaux
qui peuvent en découler et la prise de
conscience politique peut faire avancer
l'europe vers ce chemin là où les
mesures prises par ailleurs par monsieur
by des états unis qui me semble pour le
coup pouvoir inspirer et il aider
l'europe à sortir du chemin de
l'ultralibéralisme car marquez son
cheminement jusqu'à maintenant et
peut-être mais on n'y est pas et je
pense que su ce qui se profile
aujourd'hui par rapport à l'ampleur du
choc et très inférieurs à ceux dont on
aurait besoin donc juste pas sûr que
l'europe soit véritablement prête
aujourd'hui pour s'attaquer de plein
front à ce qui nous attend sur le plan
social au niveau européen
prenez la question de la 2d nouvelles
technologies de la tipp digitalisation
j'en ai dix chars et déjà mentionné
c'est une menace absolument considérable
sur l'emploi de demain comment est-ce
qu'on intègre cette dimension là dans
les projections et dans la politique
structurelle européenne pour l'instant
on ne parle surtout du développement des
nouvelles technologies comme une manne
de de croissance et de productivité ce
qu'elle laisserait lesquels sont bien
évidemment mais
en omettant totalement les conséquences
qui pourraient être extrêmement négatif
sur précisément l'environnement social
et donc la stabilité politique
européenne et la capacité de l'europe à
aller de l'avant
donc je suis très dubitative sur ce
sujet là olivier mêmes questions la
crise comme un accélérateur à la
construction d'une europe plus sociale
non j'y crois pas face le loose ipad
depuis le depuis le début là on parle de
la crise sanitaire
moi je vous ai dit mon opinion là dessus
c'est à dire que la crise sanitaire
n'est que n'est qu'un catalyseur de
d'une crise qui est déjà bien présentes
depuis longtemps et et qu'on ne règle
pas on a vu les dysfonctionnements de
l'europe
moi vous savez que je suis pas un
européen convaincu c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire est donc ce que j'aimerais
surtout vise sur l'europe c'est qu'elle
nous fiche la paix et que à un moment on
récupère un peu de souveraineté et qu'on
puisse et qu'on puisse aller de l'avant
mais je ne crois pas à ce que l'europe
puisse faire quoi que ce soit pour la
bonne et simple raison qu'on le voit là
sur ce thème
c'est que vous avez besoin de
l'unanimité pour faire pour bouger le
petit doigt et que donc de toutes façons
vous aurez des pays qui ne seront jamais
d'accord parce que ils n'ont pas le même
rythme ils n'ont pas les mêmes modèles
économiques ils n'ont pas ils n'en sont
pas au même stade si vous voulez et que
donc visiblement vous ne le l'europe et
pas un blocage est un blocage depuis 20
ans et ça va continuer comme ça tant que
vous aurez une europe qui qui intègre
des pays qui ne n'ont absolument aucun
rapport les uns entre les autres et qui
donc jouent leur carte
et là je pense que là la crise l'a bien
prouvé la crise sanitaire c'est que
quand il ya des problèmes qu'est ce
qu'on fait et ben joue pour soi et à ce
moment là l'unité européenne est un
divorce flagrant à on nous fait le coup
du
le couple franco allemand mais le couple
franco-allemand ça fait un moment qu'ils
couchent plus ensemble donc voilà on est
on est sûr d d d un espèce de d'amalgamé
c'est pas une unité c'est un amalgame de
pays sont complètement différents qui
n'ont pas la même histoire qui n'ont pas
le même le même stade de développement
et qui se fiche bien de des idées des
idées fédéralistes d'une d'une europe
qui n'en finit pas de stagner depuis 20
ans et ce sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup véronique riches florès d'avoir
été parmi nous et dans cette émission je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
présidente de riches florès reasearch
olivier nous on continue avec ali
question cash questions de laurent
olivier les banques sont au coeur des pg
e peut-on dire que c'est finalement une
bonne affaire pour elle alors c'est une
bonne affaire si l'état qui a mis sa
garantie sur ses emprunts les rembourse
mais c'est pas écrit ça et justement ça
pose un problème sinon en revanche si on
les oblige à abandonner leurs créances
elle qui aujourd'hui sont extrêmement
fragiles
ça va être compliqué et ça va peser sur
leurs leurs portefeuilles de créances
qui va devenir de fait et recouvrables
et donc je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
bon calcul pour les brandt
donc si c'est l'étape c'est l'état en
fait c'est nous c'est nous qui allons
effacer la bête il ya quelqu'un il faut
quand même se mettre dans la tête qu'il
ya toujours quelqu'un au bout qui payent
donc si l'état efface la dette d'un
trait de plume et qu'il dit à ce moment
là qu'il va rembourser à la place de
celui qui avait la la qui avait
contracté la bête il va rembourser les
banques qui est-ce qui rembourser
banques c'est vous c'est nous
dans nos impôts donc il faut il faut
toujours essayer de remonter à la source
l'état s'est pas c'est pas chinois avec
avec un gros chéquier c'est nous l'état
collectivement et donc s'il est à
effacer une dette
elle n'est pas effacée pour tout le
monde c'est nous qui allons rembourser
merci olivier c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez vous la semaine prochaine et vous
serez en comparer en compagnie d'amis
rabenja balle à jean-pierre en attendant
rendez vous sur rt france pour un tv
pour découvrir à nos précédentes
émissions et puis n'oubliez pas aussi de
poser vos questions à olivier sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag rt et
cash olivier on se quitte avec votre
dernier mot bien écouter l'europe c'est
un organisme qui monte par l'escalier et
qui risque fort de descendre par la
fenêtre